[Music]
please join me
in welcoming rob hindman
you i'm rob hyneman i'm a professor
at monash university in australia
and i want to take you to a land far far
away
australia to a time long long ago
when i look more like that actually we
don't need to go that far
back maybe that far back
but actually i'm going to start about
there so i'm 17 there
so we're talking mid 80s and
i had my first computer
so the first time i was ever trying to
type a document on a computer
it looked a little bit like looked a
little bit like this
that's actually not my first word
processor but it was
a couple of years later it was called
word star 2000 i thought it was awesome
only one other person in the room old
enough to remember word star 2000
unfortunately they went bust fairly
quickly so i switched to word perfect
a few more of them which was even more
awesome because it was a markup language
and you had two sections of the screen
you could have wysiwyg at the top
and down the bottom you had markup and
you could see where bold was on and bold
was off
i mean even microsoft word does not have
that today
so this was good i used that for a while
but then when i went to university and
tried to type mathematics that wasn't so
helpful so eventually i switched to
using tech
as in not latex tech
um i used that for a while until
somebody said hey there's this other
thing just come out called latex
which uh has sort of better markup
facilities so i switched to latex
and i used that for a long time many
many years it was fantastic
could write beautiful documents i wrote
several theses
using latex lots and lots of reports for
clients
paper academic papers and so on so that
was for the writing side
and then of course i was doing data
analysis i'm a statistician so i needed
something for the statistical side
and around 1987 i discovered this
new tool what was new to me was before
the days of r
before the days of s plus it was an
early version of
s running in a new ide that
went bust in about a year but it was
called ice and that was pretty cool
so i was using s for a few years to do
my statistical computing and using latex
to do the writing so i haven't got a
screenshot of s i couldn't find one but
those of you who grew up knowing s we'll
see recognize some of those books
then eventually s plus came out and so s
plus had quite a neat ide
so s plus for the computing latex for
the writing
was pretty good actually you could do
quite a lot
except that of course you needed to keep
these things in sync
and i would be writing s-plus code
generating graphics saving them as
postscript
graphics pulling them into my latex
documents
and if i change the s plus code i then
have to rerun the latex document to make
sure it was up to date
and so i developed this way of doing
that using
um or there's i switched to r at some
point too yeah about 2000
switched to r that's was the our website
at the time
at around the year 2000 hasn't changed
very much has it
but the only thing that's different here
is it says down the bottom
um where is it says somewhere
has some sort of oh well here it is web
page is currently under construction
that that was there for a few years
okay so i invented this way of trying to
make these things work together
so a make file is a thing used by
programmers to
compile programs and so you make a small
change in some function you don't want
to recompile everything
so you can use that in other tools as
well so i was using it for r and latex
if i made a change in my r file it would
recompile the graphics if i made a
change in the latex file it would
recompile the latex
but it was smart enough to notice that
if the graphics had changed and it
needed to recompile the latex even if
the latex file hadn't changed
and i wrote these these
sort of complicated make files to do
this i thought this was super cool
i thought everyone would do this i would
i would change the way everyone did
r and latex together i wrote blog posts
about it
um his and i tweeted about it
um here's a tweet about it got one like
so you know i had a following
[Laughter]
this was 2012. um but but this guy from
the us called eway noticed and uh
he tweeted back saying or another way of
separating afrom reports and a little
link to a thing he was developing called
knitter
and i i looked down and said yeah i know
but i reckon my way simpler
does nida have any real advantages over
my approach with make files so i
persisted on for a while
and uh sort of kept an eye on on on what
ui was doing
and after a while i realized that you
know he was right
and that although makefiles are useful
for a lot of things putting the r
code and the latex stuff together was
going to make a lot more sense
and so i switched and i st and i started
trying to write my academic papers using
markdown but of course they had to have
a certain look
so then i ended up writing our markdown
templates that's a recent paper i wrote
in an our markdown template and i was
writing
paper client reports so i had to write
on our markdown template for clients
and this was life changing like this
made my life so much easier
to i was writing papers and writing
reports um
just had to have a couple of templates
and everything was good
so i put those things together and i i
couldn't think of a decent name for my
package so i called it monash
ebs templates ebs being econometrics and
business statistics the department in
which i work
and all you have to do is to use the
template and you can generate these nice
things
and the there's before i show you that
there's um
you know there's lots of stuff that goes
into the front end of an academic paper
so we need a title we need a list of
authors and where they come from their
addresses
the abstract keywords what number of
working paper it is
in my department they always want you to
stick jel codes on things
and so on so i just put all this stuff
into the yaml
and i can generate working papers i
convinced
some other people in the department that
this was the way to go
so if i put this in my yaml and it
generates this beautiful
front page and then the title page and
then away we go with the report
so it was sort of my first attempt at
writing in a markdown template
and as i said it was changed my life and
then i thought well what else
i do a lot of other writing maybe our
markdown can be used for other things
so at around the same time as this latex
s-plus
thing i also got into making websites
the web was developed in 1993 i think
it took about four months before i had a
website
and it looked a little bit like that
that was in 1997
four years later but it didn't change
that much in the first four years
some academics still have websites that
look like that
mine evolved over time so eventually it
looked like that this is handcrafted
html because there was no other way to
make
websites you put it in a text editor you
wrote html code
um and uh look to something that looked
like that
oh somewhere here s plus functions for
time
series that became the forecast package
for r eventually
but the functions were originally on my
website
um still handwriting html code
just getting better at it still
more hand crafting of html code
at this point i thought i should have my
own domain name
and so i bought one which is the one on
the screen there
don't go there
i changed my domain name to something
else with a.com on the end eventually
didn't worry about the old domain name
but because there were links to it all
over the web from all of my papers
unpleasant organization got it and has
bad stuff on there so don't go there
um then i thought handwriting html code
is
no fun there's these new things
for content management systems so i
switched to one called joomla
that was painful so i switched to
another one called wordpress which was a
little better
but slow and i was trying to write
blog posts about r and every time i
would put my r code in
it would sort of strip out everything
after the less than hyphen thinking that
this is
an html tag and then i'd have to go back
in and
sort of try to copy and paste my thing
back in and i was ending up spending
about as much time sort of trying to
put all my stuff into the blog post as
actually writing the code
so that was no fun but this stage i
switched to this url you're allowed to
go to that url that's the current one
change the theme for wordpress and then
i thought this was so this brings me to
about 2016
and ui wrote blog down
so i thought okay i use our markdown for
everything else
from all my other writing let's see if i
can make a website using this thing
called
blog down you need a theme i looked
around the place
i figured out that blogdan's built on
hugo kieran healy had a great theme he
had his website on hugo
so i forked his website deleted his
content stuck my website
my content in with permission he says in
his github repo that you're allowed to
do that
thank you kieran did all this on a very
long flight between melbourne and
amsterdam copying and pasting and making
sure everything worked
and then thought great now let's do the
r bit and it didn't work unfortunately
kieran's theme didn't work with blog
down not every hugo theme works with
blog down
so fly it home again i start again
this time i um found another theme and
then i adapted it to look like kieran's
because i still liked his website
so my own blog down theme
that's on that github repo and it's
saved so much time doing a website that
way
okay so another thing i was doing was
writing books
i my first book published in the late
90s was this one
it was by textbook standards an
extremely successful book
but i didn't make any money out of it
because the publisher makes a great deal
of money and they didn't give much to
the authors
and i decided that i would never ever do
another book
with a commercial publisher again
because they screwed my students
and didn't benefit me
so i thought if i'm going to do another
book i'm going to put it online for free
because my students wouldn't buy those
too expensive for the students to buy
so they would be looking around on dodgy
websites getting bad information about
forecasting
and using that instead of the book that
was i thought was reasonably good
so i thought let's do it online for free
this was before
book down existed i didn't know anything
i mean you i hadn't thought about it as
far as i know
so i thought let's put it all i can do
it this is and also before my website
was on
blog down so i've tried to make it in
wordpress
the first version of it came out in
wordpress
decided that wasn't so good so i
switched and i just copied
everything over to drupal in a long
painful experience
that worked better the first edition of
the book came out in in drupal
but then i saw a book down and i thought
that's what i wanted but it's just a few
years too late
so the second edition of the book i did
in book down
and that meant that i could have a latex
i could pave a pdf version and an online
version
and everything would work beautifully
and it really did make an enormous
difference
okay so that's the uh that's the book as
it is now
that's the online version it's
relatively simple css styling but it's
just running book down
the latex is more complicated because i
wanted the latex to look a certain way
that's a page from the latex version
which is sold on amazon
okay at this point i was getting right
into our markdown i'd made websites i'd
written books and i had
templates to do things what about the
slides that i use
for talks so way back in the day my
slides looked like that using latex
seminar package
and then after a while i switched to a
package called prosper which gave
nicer looking slides and then i switched
to bema
which was a little easier in some ways
to do things and then i switched to our
markdown
and that is my slides that i use these
days
so that's a package called binb bin
stands for bin is not beamer and
it generates beamer output from
our markdown and the bin bazon cran
i'm using the monash theme which is why
that has monash as a
template on the front and it's very very
easy this particular talk that is
my yaml title author i switched the date
out i'm not in the thing you can see the
date's actually here
but in the final version i switched the
date out from my twitter handle
change the font size pretty much that's
all i had to do to the to the yama and
away you go riding a mark down
super good my cv which had been
maintained for years i thought we could
do this in our markdown too
so there's my cv in our markdown that's
using the vitae package
written by mitch ohara wilde and me i
called
that particular template after my own
name because that's the template i was
using in latex
but there's other templates that you can
use and it's
again the yaml is pretty simple you just
stick in things like your twitter handle
and github
that creates this stuff at the top and
then everything else is standard
markdown there's other templates that we
put in the package if you want other
looking
cvs okay my students were writing theses
i said i found this thing called our
markdown you should all be using our
markdown it'll change your life
i wrote them a nice template stuck it on
my github
account they have to fork it and then
they just use that and it generates
theses in exactly the format that the
monash research office
thinks is correct
i became head of department recently the
chair of my department
i have to send memos to staff naturally
what am i going to send my memos in
the university template is a word
document so i switched it out and made
it into a markdown template
and i send around memos like this with
all the branding and so on
i can take off the branding and i write
the site i use exactly the same template
for writing referee reports
to for journals um
really simple gamble in this case you've
got a title you've got an author do you
want the branding on or off
so the monash branding at the top or not
and then just whichever the name of the
template which is monash ebs templates
memo
had to write letters now i've had a
department with nice
logos and stuff on the top again there
was an awful word template that the
university gave me
so i turned it into a nice markdown
template and
put it in the package this time there's
a little bit more in the yaml because
you've got to say
well i put in who i am what my
qualifications are which come in under
here
um my address i made it general enough
so that other people can switch their
names in as well
um who i'm writing to who their address
is
how i start what my signature file is
and then it all just gets generated and
it looks fantastic
and the other thing i do as a professor
as i write exams for students
again the university gives you this
awful word template
whether the logo was actually the wrong
aspect ratio it sort of squished
and the fonts change halfway through the
front page so i
made that look better still looks like
what mono says the template should look
like
and then the exam is all written in our
markdown so it's reproducible
the graphics you get pulled in
everything's great
so that's also in the package and
all you have to do is to put in what you
need on the front page which in my case
is the unit code the title
we have multiple campuses and you have
to tick these boxes to about which
campus the
exam is for so you just put in a
campus true and campus false and the box
will get ticked in the template
how long the exam is and so on and then
away you go
so basically everything i now write i
write in our markdown
i spend my life in a text editor either
writing a markdown or writing yaml
um or occasionally fixing up the
packages that produce the templates
what have i lost i can't actually
remember how to write make files anymore
um even though i thought it was the
greatest thing i i just
it's complicated and i can't remember if
i have to have a make file i'll find one
that did something similar and copy and
paste it and
hopefully that will work what have i
gained and so much faster
both in terms of the ability to write
things but also the speed at which
documents get rendered the speed at
which my website runs
that the speed at which i can update
things
it's just incredibly and it's an
incredible
gain in speed it's so much simpler the
documents are really really simple i
don't have all that latex preamble at
the top of my documents i just have a
fairly simple
yaml header everything i do is text so
it's really simple
it's all github all on git repositories
so you've got
version control everything's
reproducible
there's enormous gains by switching to
our markdown for
pretty well everything in my life so
when i was writing this i thought well
do i write anything
these days that's not in our markdown
and i can only think of
about about these items that i
still type on my computer but i'm not
inside on our markdown document
one is i maintain the tennis club
website one is
uh i write shopping lists sometimes and
i type them out
and uh email social media tweeting and
that sort of stuff
so i thought well okay i can solve this
so i went and recreated my
tennis club website nr markdown before
between the time i started
this talk and now it's now all running
in our markdown
runs about 30 or 40 times faster than it
used to run
and it's much much easier to maintain i
don't think i'll bother with the
shopping lists they're actually not too
bad without their markdown
but email would be great
so anyway i'm not sure what your plans
are next but i'd like to see mail down
please
with a chrome browser plugin so when
someone sends me an email i can just hit
reply
and it'll come up with an r markdown box
then i can go knit and send
and away
so i just like to finally just say thank
you to you i you really did make my life
so much easier
i'm sorry i didn't believe you when you
first said have you looked at mirror
but you were right and i was wrong thank
you for that
so the slides for this talk and all the
links to packages and links to
anything else that i've mentioned are
going to be on that uh if you just go to
that link there
thank you perfect thank you
we have time for just a few questions
but i'll be sure to share all these
with you any advice on converting
awful word template to beautiful are
markdown templates
oh that's that's actually really hard
i've i i look at the word template
and i copy and paste the text and then i
just start from scratch i don't try to
do anything
in the word styling itself i just start
again
because it's i find the word templating
is too difficult to convert
what which aspects of building templates
are related yaml that are particularly
challenging or error prone
what advice would you give to a novice
in this area
um so almost all of the templating i've
done
has been with pdf so it's latex and the
back end
so you do have to be quite good at
knowing about latex but i've been using
it for 20 years so that was not a
problem
but writing a pdf template you have to
know a reasonable amount of latex to
know how to
do that i have less experience at
writing html
templates and no experience at all of
writing word templates so i
don't i wouldn't even know how to do
that yeah
someone else asked do you use bootstrap
or other frameworks to style your
templates
no okay and this is getting a few uh
upvotes here i like
our markdown but i find google docs much
easier for collaboration
and iteration with others any thoughts
on that
so google docs are fun as long as you
don't have a lot of r
to do but putting in our graphics inside
a google doc is
as you know there's cutting and pasting
to happen there
so that's painful so i find our markdown
works much much better
if you've got any real statistical
computing happening and for
collaboration purposes
um you know i
generally try and teach my collaborators
how to use github
um and mostly
that that works okay occasionally i'm
working with people that
don't know github or or are not prepared
to learn to use it and then it's a
little painful
yeah there's lots of emails and
can you please change this section
here's the words that i want to add in
but
and things like that yeah thank you very
much rob